you like a good prank like you'd like to
play a good prank your co-star Andrew
Lincoln I understand you've you've
played pretty good pranks on him
why don't you mess with his car isn't
right oh yeah yeah I've done a bunch
yeah yeah he's losing that prank war
he'd should have given up a long time
ago yeah you know in Georgia it's super
hot so I dumped like maybe three pounds
of glitter in his air conditioner and
you can't not put on your air
conditioner in Georgia right and I and
so for months he just put it on and
glitter comes shooting out oh yeah well
first he goes poof and then what's that
sound again boo boo look oof but like
four months so he always that glitter
stuck to his kind of hurt walking dead
for a while remember those scenes where
he he was super pissed off but then he
tried to get me back at Comic Con and he
I mean blessed sorry he was he was
sitting there with his fists balled up
full of glitter under the table for the
whole time we're doing like a panel that
you were yes yeah Paul H which is mass
massive Hall yeah and he's sitting there
like this the whole time and and uh and
then at one point he went to blow it in
my face and like we're on the jumbotron
like our heads are gigantic him and he
goes to blow it in my face anybody
cupped his hand like this blue it is own
face yeah say a glare it is beard and it
was Lincoln in front of about 85,000
people in Hall age